[Music]
carrie underwood brought gospel
greatness to nashville
with her performance at the acm awards
it is
thy faithfulness
[Music]
the country star gave us chills with
amazing grace
and how great thou art and was even
joined on stage by cc winans for the two
duet performances
greatest thy faithfulness in the old
rugged cross
underwood collaborated with winans for
her album my savior
which debuted at number one on
billboard's country in christian charts
it was awesome i got a chance to go in
and kind of just do my part because she
had really had already did hers and when
i finished she changed some things and
i just love it it's a beautiful song
first of all the hymns are just powerful
her voice spectacular underwood also
scored a nomination for video of the
year for her duet with john legend
hallelujah
[Music]
of course underwood's latest nom follows
her record-breaking win
at last year's acm awards when she
became the first woman to win
entertainer of the year
three times big night for sure it feels
great bt caught up with underwood
backstage last year
where she reacted to her impressive
milestone and opened up about being an
inspirational figure for women in
country music
look fantastic darling i gotta say look
you have been nominated so many times
you have a wildly passionate fandom
tonight you may have tied but you are
the first woman who has walked away with
three entertainer of the year awards
it's when you're since you're allowed so
how does it feel holding that statue
right now
it feels great um i mean obviously
there's
so many people that you know make make
our worlds go around
um so just to to be able to hold this
for
myself of course but for all of them um
it's just it means a lot and
you know it's i i like to share
i like to share with people so um i just
think it's
it's just really great that you know of
course it's 20 20
nothing is going to be like normal
nothing's going to be you know
why not i feel like a tourist still you
know
and i'm i'm waiting for the day that i
always say i'm
waiting for people to figure me out and
and leave me behind or something i don't
know can't have too much of a good thing
so i would always love to see to see
more women
and more women represented and given
opportunities but you know we've been
taking
steps in the right direction for um a
while now which is really nice to see
it was just i think it was a really
great night for for that for females in
in country music and i look forward to
more